Allo, Ben?
Qu'est-ce que tu fous?
J'ai le dernier épisode là.
-Ouais mais je suis bloqué au bureau là.
Demain soir je peux finir plus tôt,
est-ce que ça te va?
Attends, tu te rends compte
de ce que tu me demandes?
Mec, ça fait cinq ans
qu'on regarde la série ensemble,
tu m'attends.
-Bah ouais mais ...
Non, je ne plaisante pas avec toi.
Tu regardes pas, tu m'attends.
Ok.
Salut.
-Salut.
Oh, dis donc, c'est quoi cette tête?
Ah, t'es dégouté pour l'épisode 9
Quoi?
-T'as vu qui c'est qui meurt?
Non, justement, j'ai pas vu.
-Bon attends, je te raconte juste...
Non, tu ne me dis rien du tout !
-Oh mais attends...
Non non, tu dis pas.
Tu dis pas, tu dis pas, tu dis pas.
...Le gars...
-Tu dis pas, tu dis pas.
T'abuses,
c'est un tout petit truc de rien du tout!
Allo?
-Ouais, c'est Ben, ça va?
On t'a pas spoilé?
-Non, mais...
je sais pas si je vais tenir...
-C'est très simple,
pas de pause café,
c'est trop dangereux,
ensuite à midi tu bouffes tout seul
devant ton ordi
et pas d'Internet, pas de téléphone,
ça devrait bien se passer, ok?
Attends, et comment je fais pour bosser moi?
-Attends. Tu dis pas, tu dis pas!
Allo Ben? ... Ben?
T'aurais pas un peu de monnaie?
- non j'ai juste de quoi m'acheter un paquet de chips...
Mais dis-moi,
t'as pas vu l'épisode 9 toi?
Euh tu sais quoi, je t'invite.
Ben voilà !
-Bonne journée.
Eh, t'as fait quoi hier soir?
Ehh, tu dis pas!
Tu dis pas là, ok?
Tu dis pas!
Tu dis pas, merde!
Tu descends avec moi?
-Merde!
Ah mec,
faut juste que je te raconte un truc.
Enculés!!!
Vous m'aurez pas!
C'est Ben! Ouvre-moi!
Comment ça se fait que t'es là si tôt?
-Je tenais plus.
Personne ne t'as spoilé?
...Non...
Tu mens
-Non, c'est rien du tout,
C'est trop tard, ils t'ont eu!
Il est temps que tu saches,
je vais te dire qui a été tué...
Non tu dis pas, eh tu dis pas!
Oh putain.
Oh je suis con, merde!
Malcolm?
Ouais, t'as vu l'épisode 9 toi?
Tu peux me raconter?